aquí tenemos un círculo y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es encontrar la
longitud del diámetro a ve te recomiendo
que detengas el vídeo e intentes el
problema por tu cuenta
bueno vamos a ver qué sucede aquí
tenemos que ave es un diámetro porque
justo pasa por el centro de la
circunferencia déjame marcar entonces en
color verde al diámetro ahí tenemos el
diámetro ave ahora además de eso tenemos
el ángulo
cb y el ángulo acb es un ángulo inscrito
que abre al arco ave a este arco de acá
que también estoy pintando en color
verde sale y notemos que este arco es el
arco correspondiente el arco
correspondiente a este ángulo central al
ángulo digamos a v y ese ángulo justo es
la mitad de un círculo y por lo tanto
mide 180 grados
como acb es el ángulo inscrito
correspondiente a ese mismo arco
entonces mide la mitad de 180 grados es
decir
este ángulo de acá es de 90 grados es un
ángulo recto 90 grados sale entonces
tenemos que el triángulo acb es un
triángulo rectángulo y por lo tanto
podemos aplicar el teorema de pitágoras
tenemos que 15 al cuadrado 15 elevado al
cuadrado más 8 elevado al cuadrado más
88 elevado al cuadrado es igual a la
longitud de ave elevada al cuadrado
déjame llamarle x a eso es igual a x al
cuadrado de este lado queda x porque es
la hipotenusa ya que es opuesta el
ángulo de 90 grados vamos a resolver
esta esta ecuación 15 al cuadrado es 225
a eso tenemos que sumarle 8 al cuadrado
es decir 84 164 64 y eso es igual a x al
cuadrado y x al cuadrado 225 64 es 289
289 eso es igual a x al 4
a x al cuadrado y por lo tanto x x es
igual
a 17 sale 289 17 al cuadrado
entonces sacando raíz de ambos lados lo
puedes verificar por tu cuenta nos queda
que x es igual a 17